[Applause]
oh yeah
all right
[Applause]
stop it
take that outnumbered
happy Friday and you know what we do
first let's welcome tonight's guests
he's so well dressed he makes salads
jealous social scientists and YouTube
hosts hotep Jesus
he's so hot he could be my twin brother
co-host of Fox and Friends Weekend Pete
hexagon
she's she's like an earthworm small
slender and thrives in dirt Fox News
contributor Kat Tim
and finally when he sneezes four states
issue tornado warnings my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Heavyweight
Championship
all right before we get to some news
stories and we have some new ones some
Blockbusters if you will let's do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm wish I had a fridge like that
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading these so if they
suck it's on you
that doesn't make any sense but who
cares here we go Hershey's is facing a
boycott after putting a trans person's
face on a rapper commemorating
International women's day but the
company agreed to compromise and only
use the photo on Mr goodbars
I would have said no if it were me I
would have said they would only put it
on candy bars with nuts
that's better huh uh Hershey also
apologized for referring to the model's
breasts as Milk Duds
my joke was better
Green Bay Packers quarterback Aaron
Rodgers recently spent four days
meditating in a light deprived
underground retreat he said the darkness
and isolation will prepare him in case
he's traded to the Jets
foreign
Sports joke I don't get it
tensions are high following Nigeria's
elections
after president-elect Bola tanubu was
declared the winner with 8.9 million
votes the opposition maintains the real
winner is a prince who only needs a few
bucks to cover processing fees
so bad oh man during a White House
reception marking Black History Month
President Biden quipped I may be a white
boy but I'm not stupid prompting fact
Checkers to insist he's both
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
awarded the order of friendship to
action movie star Steven Seagal the last
person to give Segal that award was of
course Jenny Craig
a new lawsuit claims that NFL films
maintains a database of cheerleaders
buttocks breasts and cleavage shots in
response the NBA was like no you two
there you go
earlier this week NYC received its
biggest snowfall of the Season totaling
over three inches
foreign
New Yorkers say it wasn't much which is
confusing because I always thought three
inches was plenty
like why even
at least it was funny
and finally a code defended in the theft
of Lady Gaga's dogs is suing for the
reward because Lady Gaga said it would
be no questions asked when President
Biden heard there was a reward for no
questions asked he said we should give
that to reporters
[Applause]
now for some news is it time to retire
the bra with titanium underwire true the
breasts you can't believe have been
placed on leave it can only mean one
thing
we report down here you're watching
kazumbagate Canada 2023
week 24. the final Reckoning
Kayla Lemieux the Canadian Woodshop
teacher whose phony Z cups could have
housed 50 Keebler elves has reportedly
been placed on leave meaning those
massive Canadian domes have finally been
sent home
if you're just tuning in and I'm sorry
for that here's a recap
this is Kayla lemieu here she is along
with her friends Brian and stelter the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice it's great in
the unlikely event of a water emergency
landing your shop teacher can be used as
a flotation device now there have been
angry protests upset parents and aroused
and Confused babies if they were States
they'd be worth 98 electoral votes but
there might be a bigger reason why no
one's talking and not because they were
motorboated into silence local Pilots
initially reported it as a collision of
weather balloons if the shoot doesn't
open you'll be fine if you land face
down
you didn't find that kind of Journalism
on Fox News Sunday
Shannon and so the school district
spokeswoman told the Toronto son Lemuel
lemoy whatever is still employed just
not on active assignment but how active
can you be when you strap two Zeppelins
to your chest
so she's still getting paid but not at a
job which seems to be the only solution
these days when dealing with nuts but at
least you can finally spend more time
with her family
laughs
that's the truly funny part of all this
she wasn't sent home for wearing her
fetish costume in front of kids she was
sent home for not wearing it more at
home or at the store wherever this guy
goes to buy reinforced bras the news
comes days after we reported that the
school board finally presented a
professionalism policy in response to
parental outrage the only problem the
policy didn't include any specific dress
code to address Kayla's knockers so like
a women's studies degree it wasn't worth
the paper it was written on
a sexist would say
most people agree akayla who reportedly
used to go by Carrie says she's intersex
and blames her bust on a rare medical
condition called gigantomas Chia which
used to be part of Yugoslavia
but now that she's temporarily out of
the classroom her bra can be returned to
its original use the teacup ride at
Disneyland
Pete uh welcome back uh
wouldn't you say I'm the Woodward and
Bernstein of big knockers I doggedly
tracked this story since day one and I
wouldn't let it go until we've got
answers why do not why am I not
considered America's newsman you are to
me okay that all that and not only have
you gotten answers but you've gotten
outcomes yes I mean this without the
dogged reporting of Gutfeld exclamation
point yes there's not the scrutiny the
outrage and now the photo I mean you see
that the amazing part about this is that
he is claiming that he suffers from you
said it gigantomastia yeah
he can't control right but he takes them
off he takes them off so somehow they
have a mind of their own goes through
they're artificially intelligent they
grow on their own they grow on their own
you take them off they go into a corner
suddenly they go
they talk through the nipple
and then in the morning he looks up and
goes they've grown again they've grown
again what do I do and then he has to
strap them on and then leave the house
you raised the right point though so
it's not what happened it's the same
thing with all the other perverted stuff
in schools you couldn't get away with it
on the street yeah but you can get away
with it in elementary school exactly
it's unbelievable you said that
yesterday that's exactly what this is
well let's just take
it out of it for a sec oh so let's when
would you wear your best stuff when you
were out looking for a mate or somebody
to hook up with or to impress when would
you wear your best stuff at night were
you going out you put your clone on your
best suit or whatever you go out the
club to attract what attention from
whoever you're interested in so where is
he putting on his best gown at
school yeah so my best guess is I hope
it's a troll yeah who's having fun with
it but the parent of me feels like he's
only doing that around young and
personal boys so that's this might be
you you make jokes but you might have
exposed something a lot greater it may
have might have saved some some young
boys or girls lives that's interesting
you know I didn't think of it but you're
right maybe I am the real hero
listen listen it pains me
pains me beyond measure
because I knew coming in here today
as much as Kat and I tried to talk him
out of this crazy he does yeah that I
had to give him praise
for
this yeah and it honestly it pains me to
say that I have pretty much the exact
same thing written down here yeah all
right you're like okay it got you know
punished for not wearing it more often I
think here that makes sense yeah because
she him they whatever apparently varies
where sometimes it's a boob day and
sometimes it's not a boob day but if
you're around kids and it's always a
boob day that's a problem exactly again
I am the real hero and I want to say two
words to you Kat never forget
powerful you won't let us no no no
Otep you've never talked about this in
public have you no I'm but I'm an expert
in this because I'm actually a trans
person oh really yeah I'm trans wealthy
so like sometimes I have money but when
people want to borrow money I'm broke
okay
but I'm gonna deviate from the rest of
the panel and say he might have a case
for discrimination here because in a
trans Community have something called
gender fluid yes right which means you
can swap in and out anytime you want so
I would love to see because I think this
is a troll and I would love to see him
do a counter suit and file for
discrimination well the thing is if it's
a troll if it's a troll man he is how
does he cover everything how does he
make sure it like this is
it's oh there's been no break in the in
the role there's no like where are where
is his where his friends and his family
to say oh that's what what's its name
Carrie that Carrie was always up to
these little pranks there's not even
like a mom or a dad or anybody it's so
freaky it's like the movie mask with Jim
Carrey yeah where you like don't have a
choice you just strap it on and then
like you transform into this new person
maybe that's what's going on
but again I hate to be that guy but I
feel like I have to when you look at
people who prey on kids No One Ever
Knows yeah so there's the oh I never saw
that he never I never saw those
behaviors because it's a secret life
it's a disguises it's all the other
things going to again I'm I hope it's
just a troll yeah but I just feel like
there's a lot of things there that don't
that may add up to something more
nefarious Pete is and what I feeling
what it's like in the military when you
rescue people and you pull people out of
burning buildings that's the same is it
much the same yeah when you're looking
at me now I'm living vicariously through
what you're experiencing do you feel
compelled right now to say to me thank
you for your service all right
don't do it
for me no
cat can she's half yeah I'm a half
veteran
you are would you yeah no yeah because
you get married and everything's split
yeah that's true that's so will you
thank him for his service on the behalf
of the veteran Community absolutely not
what
you're doing in the Cavalier where
you're talking about military service is
disgusting as a half veteran
all right enough of this hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else